部屋が寂しいこんにちははじめ社長です
ここですね私の静岡の庵家の寝室なんです
けどもお部屋がとても寂しいそりゃあもう
見てこの無機質な感じ地図傍にいる時本当
にここでてるんですけどもうレッド祖父の
継母 tv 異常なんですよ設定してでし
てパクってたからなんかものが多くなく
なっちゃって結構寂しい区床になっちゃっ
てるんですよ僕の部屋そんな部屋はもう嫌
だと言うことで今回良い某皆さん知って
ますかよ気も僕は知りませんなんか
スチームとかでき遠田面接4の歳以上を
焼いてみたいなぁ乗ってよ義母っていうの
があるんですけども俺はいつ人をダメに
するソファみたいなと思ってるんですけど
もこんななーもーいらー3個ある cg 扇
で私はじめ斜張橋4義母初デビューしてい
たいと思いますもうなんかほんと気持ち
良さそうなんでちょっと買いたいなと思っ
てましてこの後火のような空間に
両儀もうのくしょん100万円分おいてみ
たいと思いますアドのことは考えていませ
ん最近忙しくでさあ忙しいからなんかもう
癒しの空間が欲しいなぁと思って家の
お母様に代々木500万円って言ったら術
絞っていただいたんでめっちゃそうでした
けどちょっと買ってみたいと思います
よすよ用のタイトですね家の近くにヨギ某
ショップあったんですけどネットで買った
方が早いかなと思いますからちょっと
100枚分注文するは金銭感覚バグってる
人みたいな
バグってる普通に1個だけにしようと思っ
てるんですけど良い希望の商品てカラフル
なものが多いから100万円分おいたら
かなり凄いからともてちょっとソファー見
てみようわーすごいだよ義母 max
これは可愛いねぇ
ああああ20ですねみーちゃんも出てます
ねどうしてでしょ
29ぱでしょうかやばいナポリっ国
キュッパでしょうちょっとオレンジ
ちょっと元気がてそのオレンジの買い
ましょうか無数カートに入れる
10月中旬入荷予定
10月中旬にいうかやって10月中旬に
変え0じゃねーかぁねええええ抜けママっ
て買えないです雪傍証とちっちゃいですね
[音楽]
この方たちも20なんでしょうか
ちょっとじゃない国方に25,800円
でしょキャロットちゃんとこのペール
ブルーって青いのも買ってみますね4義母
マックスはも買えないのかな
こっちは帰るんだ雪4 max の
パステルコレクション塗り綺麗なんです
けど普通の雪もバックスを変えるんだと
バカ夫
えーっとじゃあブルー赤ブルがいますあぁ
イエローかちょいエロいい luire
ですね具でも初潜りピンクも初ピンクもて
減っても買ったパットはこの普通の空暑熱
もいいですね普通のクッション湯喜望
ポッドも25,800円かオレンジ買っ
ちゃいますライムグリーン後どれにしよう
かな
猫の湯喜望ラウンジャーでねこれ椅子
みたいねってなんかな
あいいすねーですねイチキュッパカこれ顔
フラミンゴし稼ぐこないんじゃフラミーも
買っちゃう後は
そそあオプションで何
ああこういうのがあるんだ米杉共通そんな
にこれよ妓房ロール max a めっ
ちー the めっちゃいいじゃん9話
フルピンクオレンジ4施設です
sa にじいろ熱があるのはグレミヨン
ってなんだろよ妓房 midi いい
サイズですね2人掛けのソファにも使える
という
oo 3つ依存依存
めっちゃいいじゃん色の展開がまたキャメ
ルって言うのだねああ
やってやれなんかすごい悪いこと設計が
石炭こんなたくさん買う人いないんだろう
な湯喜望ラウンジャー
a かわいいなにこれ独自の軽重であなた
を優しく包み込む一人をソファーこんな嘘
だったら人生終わりそうだから買っちゃく
アブル購入リンク購入オレンジ購入
グリーン購入
なにこのでかいのよ give をダブル
ゴン9800円そんな高いの館内もええ
すげえこれメッツでかそうじゃないですか
ヘアーやはぎボーってねこれ全部かいい
でしょああやばい結構魚母義母突っ込ん
だら91万まできましたねもうちょい
大概対応体制まで持つて出るラクチェ
外で使えるよう希望があるのにもレース
デー
それは買いでしょ使い動作まあ
ライムライトはい行きました商品の合計
金額は100万8150円でやばいやばい
やばいやばいやばい
入っ注文することができました
もう後には戻れませんただこのちょっと
寂しい空間を彩るのには完璧な私の
チョイスだったのではないでしょうか届く
まで結構時間かかりそうなんでしばしお
待ちを
あとだけど雨からですね約1週間2週間
くらい経ちましたえっと家の地下がですね
今
届いた全部届いたんですけども量がすごい
のなんのこれもやばいってー全部でしょ
例えば1個1個軽いなさせがですねという
わけで二むしろそこ見えないんですけど
ここも全部良いもう骨にある白いの全部4
義母で100万円の与儀を
幽霊
100枚のよ義母家に届きました
ただこれはつかなんでこれを今から全部上
に運ばなきゃいけないんですけども
ちょっと
がんばるわー
[音楽]
ああ
うおっおおっ
こりゃいい
どうだ
o 2つあ言ってたクッションですね
rarます
ああああああああラー油 j
[音楽]
だーっええええええ
が大きくなっとるさあにこともを切る後ル
パソ小山いってもう
[音楽]
同2年これ
does ねこれ
[音楽]
戦っ
ハアナーこうなるのかこうなるの角が穂が
知りたかったですというわけで与儀後人を
ダメにするソファのも最強拡張人気
メーカーさんの与儀棒の人をダメにする
ソファーとがクッションとか人形とから卵
とかもありますネットいろいろな止めて
100万円分これを僕の先生が良かったと
しか言いようがないですけどもカラフルに
なるようにカラフルになるようにいろんな
色を買った結果そんな狭いわけじゃないん
ですよこの辺一般家庭のリビングぐらいは
こんな感じになっちゃうよっていうのは
今回分かりました
どうせねこれこれ上手んえもうすごい
気持ちいいですよすべてを聞きもちんです
が素材が全部ふかふかなんですよもう
[拍手]
最高
いやの最高なんですよ体が蕩けちゃう
くらいどこにだっても体が蕩けちゃう
くらいの柔らかさなんですよもう本当にん
やっぱお前誰だよ誰だちんたみたいな顔し
てそこにも2人でシーンでもこれすごい
気持ち良さそうだったんで買いましたと彼
は怒ったってこの場も本ライダーキッズ
ティオのやつなんですよねたぶん卵は何
だろう普通にめっちゃ柔らかいです
こんな贅沢なほど内容やこのおっきいやつ
が売ってるんですけどこれがメッツ気持ち
ですねほんとにもうこのファー立たないっ
てもめっちゃ気持ちなんかもうこれだけで
いいです極論を言うとこれでいいんです
けどやっぱりあの100万円分母とどう
なるのかなっていう素朴な木本お金がやっ
てみたら抱く癒してないしこれが俺の望ん
でて部屋の姿ですベッドがなくなっちゃっ
たけど本当のしばらくここでこうやって
いけると思うんでよろしくお願いします
えっふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
[音楽]
ああ
ありがとうござい
[音楽]
relん
ああああああああああああええええええ
th
tar
ああああああ
止まります
じゃあ